الذي قادنا الى الى هذا الوضع هو تراكم من
السياسات القطريه في المنطقه التي ساهمت
في تقويض امن المنطقه واستقرارها
ولعبت دور في تاجيج التطرف وفي تاجيج
العديد من الجماعات المتطرفه وفي دعم بعض
الجماعات الارهابيه فما نراه اليوم ليس
وليد لحظه بل
هو تراكم هذه السياسات ادى ب الى هذا
الوضع وهو ليس بشان استقلال القرار القطري
فهناك العديد من القرارات المستقله ضمن
مجلس التعاون ولكنه بشان التاجي
وال تقويض الامن في في الدول الجاره
الشقيقه وفي المنطقه بوجه عام العديد من
الخطوات التي تم اتخاذها على الصعيد
الاقتصادي سواء من السعوديه او الامارات
او البحرين او مصر او الدول الاخرى هي
خطوات هدفها الاول هو ارسال رساله واضحه
للقياده القطريه بان تصرفاتها السابقه غير
مقبوله وان لها تكلفه ولها ثمن وبالتالي
لابد من ان تكون هناك اعاده نظر واعاده
هيكله لتوجه السياسه القطريه في المنطقه
على المدى الابعد من الصعب ان يكون لك جار
هو شريك في نفس التكتل السياسي والاقتصادي
ولكن ايضا عبر سياساته يحاول ان يقوض
الامن والاستقرار في منطقتك وفي بلدك وهو
وضع صعب التعايش معه وقد تعايشنا معه مده
طويله ولكن اعتقد حبل الصبر قد
نفذ